Nos piden simplificar,
"r" a la 2/3 por "s" cúbica,
todo esto elevado al cuadrado,
que multiplica a la raíz cuadrada de "20r" cuarta,
"s" a la quinta.
Esto se ve amenazante, pero si lo hacemos paso a paso vas a ver que va a ser fácil.
Tomemos para empezar esta expresión de aquí,
donde estamos elevando al cuadrado un producto,
sabemos que para hacer esto elevamos cada uno
de estos términos al cuadrado
y luego hacemos el producto.
Esto es entonces,
"r" elevado a la 2/3
y eso elevado al cuadrado,
que multiplica a "s" al cubo, elevado al cuadrado.
Ahora veamos este radical, es prácticamente lo mismo,
pues sacar la raíz cuadrada de algo
es elevar ese algo a la 1/2.
Así es que esto lo podemos escribir...
lo anterior lo multiplicamos por...
voy a usar otro color para hacer esto...
20, pero en vez de escribir 20,
lo voy a factorizar con el producto
de un cuadrado perfecto y algo más,
es decir,
esto lo podemos escribir como
4 por 5
eso sería este 20,
que multiplica a "r" a la cuarta,
por "s" a la quinta,
y voy a hacer lo mismo con "s" a la quinta,
lo voy a escribir en términos de un cuadrado perfecto.
Aquí "r" la cuarta ya es un cuadro perfecto, la raíz cuadrada de "r" a la cuarta ese "r" cuadrada,
así es que "s"a la quinta
lo voy a escribir como,
"s" a la cuarta, que multiplica a "s",
"s" a la cuarta por "s" es "s" a la quinta,
y todo esto elevado a la potencia 1/2,
continuemos simplificando nuestra expresión.
Si tenemos algo elevado a la 2/3
y eso elevado al cuadrado,
lo que tenemos que hacer,
es multiplicar los exponentes.
Entonces este término de aquí va a ser igual a
"r" elevado a la 4/3,
y este "r" a la 4/3
lo puedes ver de 2 maneras.
Puedes verlo como "r" a la 1/3,
la raíz cúbica de "r" elevado a la cuarta potencia,
o puedes verlo como "r" elevado a la cuarta potencia,
a la cual está sacando la raíz cúbica.
Esas dos interpretaciones son válidas para "r" elevado
a una potencia fraccionaria como lo es 4/3.
Tenemos entonces "r" a la potencia 4/3 que multiplica a
"s" elevado al cubo, elevado al cuadrado.
Entonces que multiplica a "s" a la sexta potencia,
ahora, podemos elevar cada uno de estos términos a la potencia 1/2,
así es que
esto multiplicado por...
déjame distinguirlo por colores...
sería 4 elevado a la potencia 1/2...
quizás ya no voy a necesitar paréntesis...
que multiplica a
5 elevado a la potencia 1/2,
que multiplica  a
"r" a la cuarta,
elevada a la potencia 1/2
y esto que multiplica....
se me están acabando los colores...
"s" a la cuarta
elevada a la potencia 1/2
y finalmente que multiplica a "s"...
"s" elevado a la potencia 1/2.
Hay muchas maneras de hacer esto,
pero lo primero que brinca aquí,
pues así lo construimos,
es que hay varios cuadrados perfectos a los cuales
les podemos extraer raíz cuadrada.
Hagamos eso, 4 a la 1/2 es 2,
la raíz cuadrada principal de 4,
eso que multiplica a 5 a la 1/2,
vamos a escribirlo simplemente como
la raíz cuadrada de 5,
que multiplica a "r" a la cuarta, a la 1/2.
Aquí hay 2 maneras de verlo,
esto es lo mismo que "r" a la 4 por 1/2,
que es "r" a la 4/2,
ó también puedes verlo como la raíz cuadrada de
"r" cuarta que es, "r" cuadrada,
"s" a la cuarta elevado a la 1/2,
es exactamente lo mismo,
es "s" a la 4/2 que es "s" cuadrada,
y finalmente el último factor de este producto,
que es "s" a la 1/2 que es igual a la raíz cuadrada de "s".
Así queda esto entonces y veamos qué más podemos hacer aquí.
Tenemos...
déjame escribir los otros términos,
tenemos "r" a la 4/3,
que multiplica a "s" a la sexta por 2,
por raíz cuadrada de 5, por "r" cuadrada,
por "s" cuadrada y por raíz cuadrada de "s",
hay varias cosas que podemos hacer aquí,
podemos combinar estos términos en "s" primero...
o no, mejor vamos a poner este término este 2 primero.
Entonces esto es 2, ahora las "s" tenemos "s" a la sexta, por "s" cuadrada, aquí podemos sumar los exponentes.
Cuando se nos pide simplificar hay
muchísimas opciones para esto,
en este caso vamos a hacer "s" a la sexta
por "s" al cuadrado,
"s" a la 6 más 2 ó "s" a la octava
y esto por... veamos los términos en "r"....
Esto es interesante, pues... pues la manera de agruparlos va a depender de lo que consideremos
que es simplificar.
Tenemos "r" a la 4/3 por "r" al cuadrado...
"r" a la 4/3  por el "r" al cuadrado...
"r" a la 4/3 es lo mismo que "r" a la 1, más 1/3,
eso es lo que es "r" a la 4/3,
sumando 2 de "r" cuadrada, nos resulta que,
"r" a la 4/3 por "r" cuadrada,
es igual a "r" a la 3 enteros 1/3,
y esto puede ser un poco confuso,
pues aquí estoy sumando las fracciones
y por acá con la "s", la dejé como radical,
en vez de una exponente fraccionaria.
Podemos jugar con todo esto,
pero al final de cuentas son expresiones válidas.
Ya incluimos las "s", ya incluimos las "r",
nos falta incluir a raíz de 5 y raíz de "s",
que podríamos poner como una sola expresión, pero
no lo voy a hacer aún, las voy a poner por separado.
Así es que esto por raíz de 5 y por raíz de "s".
Ahora, aquí hay 2 cosas que podemos hacer,
quizás no nos guste este exponente fraccionario
y lo podemos separar o podemos junta,
raíz de "s" con "s" a la octava,
pues ya sabemos que esto es lo mismo que "s" a la 1/2,
hagamos las dos.
Si quisiéramos dar una respuesta
con exponentes fraccionarios,
esto quedaría como 2 que multiplica a
"s" a la octava, por raíz cuadrada de "s",
que es "s" a la 1/2, así es que esto sería
"s" a la 8 enteros 1/2,
o "s" elevado a la 8.5,
también lo podemos escribir así,
es "s" elevado a la 8 enteros 1/2 que es "s" a la 8.5,
y esto que multiplica a
"r" elevado a la 3 enteros 1/3,
estamos combinando notaciones,
aquí tengo notación decimal
y aquí tengo notación fraccionaria con números mixtos,
y eso por la raíz cuadrada de 5.
Esta es una simplificación la tengo, por así decirlo,
en los menos términos posibles.
La otra simplificación, si no queremos estos
exponentes fraccionarios que tenemos aquí,
esto lo podemos escribir como...
lo voy a hacer en un color distinto...
esto lo puedes escribir como...
no olvidemos que ambas son expresiones equivalentes,
esto depende de cómo interpretas simplificar,
así es que esto lo puedo escribir como 2
que multiplica a "s" a al octava,
que multiplica a "r" a la 3 enteros 1/3,
que podemos escribir como "r" al cubo,
por "r" a la 1/3
y "r" a la 1/3 es la raíz cúbica de "r",
así es que por la raíz cúbica de "r".
Y luego tenemos la raíz cuadrada de 5 y la raíz cuadrada de "s",
ambos están elevados a la potencia 1/2,
así es que lo podemos escribir en un solo radical,
quedando como la raíz cuadrada de 5s.
Me gusta más ésta del lado izquierdo,
para mí esto es realmente simplificar,
tenemos las bases expresadas una sola vez,
aquí tenemos estos 2 números, los términos en "s" están aquí, los términos en "r" están aquí...
ésta es un poco más complicada, tenemos
una raíz cúbica, hemos separado las "s" y las "r",
yo me iría con ésta, si alguien me dijera
"Oye Sal simplifica esto, como a ti te gusta más".